thank you very much for coming into the
studio weekend before the general
election and we just heard Boris Johnson
there lay out his plans for immigration
if he becomes the next prime minister
what Slater's plans then do you want to
go Jew would you want to see numbers go
up or down and what you make but we
should have a fair a fair immigration
system a fair and balanced immigration
system of course we should but he's
imposing a tax on nurses coming from the
EU and beyond to come and work here in
our NHS to care for our sick and an
elderly he's going to exacerbate the
stuffing crisis in our NHS with his
proposals and he's also misleading the
British people because he's trying to
give them the impression that he's going
to bring immigration down but when you
look at the details of what he's
announced today he's saying he's gonna
hand over decisions on who will get a
visa to an independent committee he said
the committee will be independent in the
same way the Bank of England is
independent so he's actually misleading
people when he says he's bringing
immigration down
there'll be no democratic control
there'll be no accountability over any
decision that any Immigration Minister
makes because they'll be handed over to
a statutory independent committee so I'm
again Boris Johnson's lying to the
British people strong word they're lying
and it's a strong word but it is I mean
you call him out on the fact that he's
not delivering 50,000 extra nurses
didn't you he had to admit because you
put him under pressure that it's only
31,000 new nurses so again that was a
lie and his 40 hospitals are alive
what's Labour's policy then well we need
if do you want immigration to go up but
no you want an immigration system which
reflects your needs in the economy so
for example if a hospital thinks that a
a nurse or a surgeon is qualified to
come here to care for our sick to carry
out operations on people who need
operations and my god people need
operations with the waiting list at four
and a half million under the table is
worse waiting list ever at the moment
under the tourists then that hospital
should be allowed to give that those
people should be allowed to come here so
you have an immigration system that
reflects the needs of your economy
economy needs it would you be happy to
see immigration levels go up under a
Labour government many people would say
that was absolutely reasonable if the
economy if the economy needs it then of
course people should come here to work
in our economy whether it's their
national health services we're about
happy to see
whereas the National Health Service
where they were desperate shortages
after ten years of mismanagement about
the tourists or of a part of our kind of
me that needs people care sex we're
going to talk about social care today
our social care sector runs on immigrant
labor and if the Tories are cutting off
that immigrant labor from our social
care sector then our social care sector
would collapse if you win the election
Labour's policy is to negotiate a new
deal with the EU and you brexit deal
would free movement of people come to an
end under that deal well that depends
what's in the deal isn't it but what
we're very clearly negotiating it well
well it really depends what's in that
deal I mean but I think actually free
movement has been good for the UK
economy public services like the NHS
have benefited hugely from free movement
across the European Union which is why
I'm able to go into which well these
things will be negotiated
but it's worried for example that we
should absolutely maintain free movement
for the National Health Service and the
social care sector because they are both
sectors that literally could not survive
if we did not continue to recruit
internationally which is why the
proposal to slap a 400 pound tax on
nurses coming from the EU is highly
irresponsible from Boris Johnson so is
there a brexit deal that you
theoretically could support personally
well we'll see what gets negotiated I
mean I vote well I've always been pretty
clear that I think Britain the United
Kingdom's best interests for the future
a best served by remaining within the
European Union that's why I campaigned
for a main that's why I think that to
remain if it should be on a be put to
the people and they should decide in the
end in a referendum
I've always been clear on that some
people listen to you'll be like what's
the point of labor even going into these
negotiations if so many people like
yourselves are saying quite openly
already that you think remain is
effective because because we lost the
argument in the country didn't we I mean
the country voted to leave so I think
the responsible thing now is to bring
both sides of the country back together
and say to the country look this is what
leave looks like right because you know
Boris Johnson after all these starting
busses going around the country saying
it before hundred fifty million extra a
week well that never turned out to be
true did it so this is what leave looks
like this is a credible leave but if you
if you don't think that is what you what
you want for the country you here
your chanting is your opportunity to
remain are you ruling out any supporting
any deal that a Labour government could
well I think how about our country's
best interests are served by remaining
but I also are well but I'm also aware
that the country needs to make the final
decision and in the end it's the British
people who will decide oh you've got an
announcement about social care this
morning what what is labour planning to
do well essentially we're announcing
free personal social care because you
know you throughout this election
campaign you've seen stories of
heartbreaking stories of elderly people
languishing on trolleys in hospital
corridors sometimes for hours upon hours
of ninety nine year old war war veteran
Danny Kent
waiting for ten hours in a hospital in a
hospital cover toll on a tram it's
really quite shameful that the fact that
Boris Johnson can't get a grip if this
is it's quite palling actually when you
think about it part of the reason why
our NHS is under such intense pressure
is yes ten years of cutbacks across
health services but we've had these
savage cuts to Social Care budgets this
is the support the elderly people get in
the community to stay in their home so
we're gonna put more support in we're
gonna fund it properly ten billion
pounds extra and we're gonna introduce
free personal care because I don't want
to have people languishing on trolleys
in hospital corridors but hours and
hours hours no one will have to pay
anything it means that no one will have
to pay anything for the care that they
get in their home as support getting out
of bed support with cleaning yeah but
but this is about ensuring fairness in
the system it's been something well
we're putting ten billion pounds extra
in and that you know this issue on
social care has been ducked by parties
for years now hasn't it Boris Johnson
said the other big priority for it or a
big plan for it on the steps of Downing
Street and his plans vanish doesn't he
hasn't got a plan so we think it's time
to put forward he's serious credible
costed plan for Social Care which is why
we're putting ten billion pounds extra
int into the system to provide everyone
with free personal care I mean ten
billion pounds is already a big chunk of
money the Institute for Fiscal Studies
says that because of the aging
population because of the growing
pressures the amount of money needed the
Social Care is gonna keep going up and
up is this a blank cheque we just keep
putting in as much money as needed so
that everybody no matter how wealthy can
have free personal care well we are an
aging society and the fact that we've
ducked this issue as a country for so
long is a disgrace really
and what Boris Johnson wants to do is
have more sort of discussions and
commissions it's a blank check for
however much it costs but look you know
labour government will keyboard but you
can sell about it free you can share
about any any any aspect of public
services is NHS a platen listen check is
the school's a blank check we're going
to come and having children as a nation
is in funding schools is a blank check
of course of course government's always
make decisions about how to fund
services for the future but we will we
will invest in public services and we
think the right way to do that is by
asking the welfare and society those
were the broadest shoulders to pay a
little bit extra in taxation to fund our
public services and that would include
the national care service that we're
announcing today I mean some more think
this just sounds like more free things
from labor more spending and they'd be
questioning and how this is going to be
paid for in the future well as I've said
we will make different decisions on
taxation I mean we have had for 10 years
and our Conservative government giving
big tax cuts to corporations big tax
cuts to the wealthiest well at the same
time cutting Social Care and cutting
health services I don't think they are
the right choices for the country
particularly when you look at where we
are now with four and a half million
people on the waiting list we've got
news today that people have captain
we've got the worst cancer weights in
ever on record as people with cancer
waiting longer for treatment and of
course this Christmas today there'll be
135,000 children in this country not
homeless not in in simply accommodation
I think that's disgraceful these are the
things we need to turn around which is
why we're prepared to put up tax for the
wealthiest to fund public services and
fund tackling child poverty the
Conservatives have said that if they win
the election they want to get different
parties around the table and come up
with a cross-party solution to the
social care crisis if you aren't still
the shadow health secretary after the
election well I won't be to the health
sector well I know I know you want to
win but if the if there is a chance that
you don't win would you be prepared to
get run a table with the Conservatives
and come on up and then the question is
where is question we aren't going to
legislate to introduce a national care
service so the question is well as
conservatives vote for our national care
service or will they vote against it
really cuz we're going to be the
government it's a really serious
question it is especially to work we're
not in opposition we're going to be in
government what we won't just wait in
gauging at all but why won't you just
say that you get around the time
with the opposition well when I am the
Secretary of State for health I will
invite the shadow health secretary inter
to discuss our national care plans and
see if they wants to support them on our
even so that's it so that's our so we've
just said we'll have a cross-party
discussion we'll discuss our national
care plan and the fact that we're
putting 10 billion pounds extra into
social care so what do I know you don't
want to talk about losing but you may
lose and if you do well well if we lose
what would you be prepared in theory to
get on the table with the conservative
I'm always serious
I'm always it shouldn't be party time oh
I'm always prepared to talk to whoever
you know I'm and that's the sort of guy
I am
but look I'm gonna be the health
secretary we're gonna have a Labour
government and we're gonna have a Labour
government to fix the waiting lists
which are fallen half million to fix the
cancer waiting lists and to fix Social
Care which has been denied which has
been avoided for years by governments
okay and it's pretty clear that you want
to be the health secretary after lecture
we've got that message through and
however you gov and data praxis have
published their latest seeing rejection
poll which is looking at all the
different constituencies modeling how
the polling would map how if there was a
general election held right now and of
course things can still change we still
got four days to go but it shows this
poll that although things have been
narrowing the Conservatives in their
view are still on for a majority you can
see they're 344 seats are projected for
the Conservatives 221 for labour if you
look at this are you worried well look
look you know that's an opinion poll
there's a few days ago and I think the
question out or the point I would say to
British people the people of watching
you the program this morning is look you
know do we really want five more years
of the Tories running our NHS when
there's four and a half million people
on the waiting list five more years of
the tour is failing to deal with cancer
when people got cancer and not getting
the treatment on time I mean and it's
like to paraphrase a famous former
Labour leader you know I warned people
not to get ill with five more years of
the tour is wrecking their nature - five
more people not to get not to get poor
with child poverty going through the
roof one of the tour is these are the
issues which people have to be thinking
about on Thursday do we really want five
more years of the tour issued on our NHS
if it means that they're going to end up
with more seats now than before well you
know because you have missed out because
in the end we had to go for an election
didn't we because we hunted we want to
put on program to the government when
the NHS is in the
that is in with people waiting on
trolleys for hours upon hours then of
course we had to go from the general
election to kick out this Tory
government to save the NHS and there's a
few days left to go and I will be in the
next few days pushing that message even
harder do you want five more years of
the Tories wrecking our NHS cutting
Social Care cutting health services and
and people and privatizing our NHS even
further you clearly feel very strongly
about the NHS under the Conservative
government so the question I guess is
why is it that Labour is still not
absolutely steam rolling ahead in the
polls and I have to say that when I go
now out and about which I have done
every week throughout the election
campaign so I'm it comes up quite a lot
is Jeremy Corbyn I mean is that
something you hear well we've got a few
days now left to go right and we'll see
what the result is on Thursday night but
this general election it really is that
no the question is is this about this
general attitudes within it wasn't a
decision and we have speaking about the
NHS my question was do you hear people
raising the question of jeremy corbyn's
leadership I heard people raising issues
around Jeremy Corbyn I have issues
people raising issues around Boris
Johnson literally yesterday on the
doorstep someone told me said to me they
do not trust Boris Johnson he will go in
with Trump and sell off our NHS I got
that on the doorstep yesterday from a
voters even though Trump said this week
that he said I quote we had absolutely
nothing to do with it and we wouldn't
want want to if you hand it to it on a
silver platter yeah but it's not what
you said to that person with Dawson no
it's not it's not what I said to that
person that asked that why sets we want
that person our doorstep is what Donald
Trump wants is to smash up the way in
which regulatory regime works for
medicines because he has said he thinks
other nations are freeloading when it
comes to purchasing drugs which is why
US US firms cannot get the prices for
drugs that they want in other countries
and that is what and the Americans have
made it explicit that they want the UK
and other countries around the world to
pay more for u.s. drugs and that would
be an explicit part of a trade Hale and
the Tories cannot rule out it will cost
was up to 500 million pounds a week and
what I mean cuts cuts to stuffing it'll
mean people waiting longer for treatment
because the money won't be there in the
NHS one of the Tories if you lose the
election on Thursday you won't lose
jeremy corbyn's stand down we're not
going to lose the election
we're gonna win okay Jonathan I swear
thank you very much coming the program
today thank you